hey youtubers is charlie the BBC just
dropped a brand-new TV trailer for The
Doctor Who Christmas special we got a
much better look at the aliens and we
got some details about the special
itself new round of the giveaway starts
now it's a twenty dollar amazon gift
card all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll name a winner whenever I post
my next Doctor Who video next week the
official synopsis reads four crew
members of an ice cap polar base Ashley
Carter bellows professor albert and
Shana are under attack from the alien
control fari fortunately for them help
is on the way but desperate the other
situation is how willing will they be to
accept one rescuer who rives in a police
box and another who turns up on a sleigh
pulled by flying reindeer and then
there's the quote listed it's Christmas
Day it's the North Pole and you're dying
who you gonna call so these obviously
are the Contras fari the real question
is is why does the doctor need Cara's
help it does seem like a very the doctor
saves Christmas with the help of Santa
Claus and Clara so Steven Moffat wrote
the special he called it scary tense and
claustrophobic the thing meets Miracle
on thirty-fourth Street it's certainly
the strangest bloody thing I've ever
written so that gives you an idea it's
gonna be really weird tale about digging
things out of the ice the aliens and
getting people to believe in Santa Claus
like the idea of the myth of Santa Claus
they did that with Robin Hood earlier
this year you know is he real is he not
real is the doctor real is he not real
as seen from Clara's perspective
obviously the doctor believes he's real
but I always loved that moment there was
a moment in Robin Hood where he wasn't
quite sure Santa is the one that
actually came for Clara first the doctor
swooped in later this is a better shot
of that base at the North Pole I'd be
interested to see how they deal with the
myth about Santa's workshop being at the
North Pole if they try to integrate that
into this North Pole base because it
seems like the teens it's there has
nothing to do with Santa it's hard to
tell from this shop but the contro for
it actually looked like they're wearing
uniforms so either they're converted
people or they got dug out of the ice
and they just bendy thawing note to self
if you ever find an alien spacecraft
buried in the ice do not dig it up or
anti aliens for that matter we do have
the names of the main cast members the
official character names nick frost we
know Santa Claus obviously Michael
Troughton the son of the second doctor
is professor albert Maureen Beatty is
bellows Faye marsay is
Natalie Gumede is Ashley Carter Nathan
McMullen is wolf and dan starkey obvious
is Ian but they're the main cast so I
would assume anyone else that does not
appear on this cast list and as a
secondary character is redshirt status
but usually Moffat picks someone off
pretty quickly to be fair the aliens
would not be a threat if someone didn't
die right away I just love the shot at
Nick Frost and strikes just swaggering
in just a giant gaping hole in the side
of the research space no big deal just
Santa Claus and his elves it is so
bizarre seeing dan starkey without his
makeup on s'ok Lauren the blackboard
here you are dying it could be
foreshadowing for her or for the people
at the research base Santa implied that
her belief in him was actually a really
big deal so that somehow might be tied
to her survival he was actually a much
better shot of the contra fari standing
up it almost looks like you can see the
skin of a human neck underneath that
giant head so it's possible that the
contrary are converting people at the
research base so just to address Clara
Oswald Steven Moffat did say that they
would address what happened in death in
heaven like the death of Danny and her
leaving the doctor like it would be part
of the episode like a big part of the
story Jenna Coleman has been back and
forth about whether or not she's leaving
right now it looks like she's going to
stay on for at least four or five
episodes of series 9 Peter Capaldi has
been reported as signing on for series 9
and 10 I've only seen that from one news
publication so look forward to more news
from that after the Christmas special or
at least around the Christmas special
the BBC will probably make an official
announcement Nick Frost has said a
couple things about his character he
said my Santa is cross mean and Kurt as
well as cheery and funny which seems
kind of all over the place seems a
little bipolar he's got a little bit of
robert deniro in mean streets and he has
a history with the doctor it's not
talked about exactly but they have a
beef with each other from way back I
just love that idea it also means that
Santa is really long lives although he's
not a Time Lord there have been a lot of
theories about that I don't think he's a
Time Lord I think they'll explain it
some other way Moffat doesn't always
explain everything in great detail look
he doesn't always get really particular
with the details so once we actually see
it we can decide whether or not he's a
Time Lord if they don't actually show
him operating a TARDIS or anything like
that presumably he's flying that sleigh
which does not look like Time Lord
technology so we'll see so I know
everyone's asking about bonus video
for the Christmas special I'm going to
start posting a couple bonus videos
starting next week so when we get within
that two week window of the actual
special itself i'll start posting during
the week so it's gonna be a lot of fun
I'm really excited the way they describe
it is going to be this one of the
weirdest Christmas specials ever so I'm
really looking forward to it but if you
guys are watching on your mobile phone
or on a tablet you can click up here now
there's new mobile links the same as the
links over here but click here for all
my other Doctor Who bonus videos and
click here to learn all about the
Sherlock Christmas special that's right
i will be doing some Sherlock bonus
videos when we get closer to Christmas
thank you so much watching so I will see
you guys tonight high fives
you